reading recently about Bartonella affecting micro circulation in the body. And that's very true,
so Bartonella infections can cause like stretch mark looking things on the skin and all sorts of
problems. I wonder if that is what is causing the agonizing pain that I get in my thighs when I walk
even 10 steps or stand more than a minute. Very possible. Lime disease and co-infections of
lime are notorious for those type of symptoms. Lime therapy any frequencies of the right
machine that could help address the issues with micro circulation to help provide some pain relief.
Absolutely nothing is helped with the pain. Well, I would go right to the Bartonella
program. So there's program for all the lime co-infections. So you can run those, the lime has Bartonella
inputs. You can run the Bartonella program. So there's all the co-infections programs on the right.
I would do those not the micro circulation. There is a circulation program too, but I would go to that
root cause of running the frequencies for the co-infections.